foreign
Joseph in Las Vegas what's up Joseph
hey Dr John how you doing good my
brother what are you doing man
uh nothing much man just started college
about a month ago
um kind of getting my life together if
that's the best way to describe it hey
if you if you if you figure out how to
get your life together in your first
semester of college you were way ahead
of the game man I didn't know what day
it was until like my junior year good
for you dude that's funny yeah I'm
trying to get my life together as of
right now it hasn't really been easy
I'll just say that you know tell me
about it tell me about it yeah well I
I've got some issues going on and I I
think that they need to really be
addressed because this is really
stealing my life and it's really
stealing
my hopes for the future and and I don't
I I think if this isn't this problem
isn't addressed with me
I really I I really think I'm gonna have
a hard time making it through adult life
and trying to
become a man because you know how old
are you the way I'm going oh I just
turned 18 about a month ago okay I don't
I don't know what you're about to tell
me
but I don't want you to give up on
yourself right now
okay I want to start this conversation
with a sense of optimism not a sense of
if I don't it's all over because you're
18 man okay
yeah is that cool
yeah I understand what you're saying I
hear you and I also know that whatever
you're working through right now feels
like it's weighing you down so let's get
into it man what what's going on in your
life yeah so ever since elementary
school I've always had this struggle
talking to women and you know it and I
feel like none of them have ever liked
me it's like if any ever did try to talk
to me
I feel like it was just you know to um
to just to I would say not to I would
always say brush me on but like to kind
of just play with me like funny kind of
to make fun of me if that's a better
word to use and I struggled with this
all through elementary school and all
through middle school and pretty much
all through high school I see other guys
who you know who are you know who who I
wouldn't say they had girlfriends I mean
I'd say they were much better than me
and they they were they had the
opportunity
have a better social life to hang out
and I I feel like you know I and then
this is might sound typical to most
people but to me it's a big struggle and
I'll tell you why because it led me down
a passive addiction that I I I really
I I really wish I would have never
started I'd say that it's it's like a
cigarette and I got into the addiction
of pornography and masturbation and I
became super heavily addicted and I
still am was like masturbating like 30
times a day and it's really bad and I
don't laugh when I say it because it to
me it's not a laughing matter no it's
hell dude it's hell it's hell it's like
a cigarette it's way worse than a
cigarette it's way worse than a
cigarette man okay you don't have to
justify it to me it's uh 30 times like
yeah you're a full-blown addict man and
that's hell
um
yeah so I'm not laughing at all with you
okay yeah and so yeah thank you John and
then so it was and then what's worse
about it is that I I feel I I feel lost
I I feel angry I feel I feel lonely and
then my mom didn't allow me to get my
driver's license till I was
18 which was this last year and so when
I would see all these people that had a
much better I would say life and I was
had no job I had no uh I had no car I I
really really felt miserable like I felt
really really
miserable and depressed and what's worse
even worse is that even till now when I
have all the opportunity to pick up more
work and to you know control my finances
and control
I I feel like that scar of the last
eight years of my life
sticks with me because it's kind of like
I got out of high school and I'm like
I wouldn't say what now but I'd say more
like you know
like it's it's just a big ball of
confusion and then dealing with this
addiction it's it's it's just I feel
like that's what's made it hard to move
out and you know not move out but uh
move on
from it and try to get away from it and
it this pornography addiction led me
down
severe it led me down a really really
severe path of insanity not only in my
addiction but in my mental health and in
the way I view things and the way I
spend money and then the way I've I so
far because of my addiction I've lost
over I'd say about three thousand
dollars in
shavings that I was supposed to use for
adulthood I spent it on uh
spent it on supporting my addiction
supporting my laziness supporting all of
this and so it it just really has not
been good and it and I want to be honest
with you John because you're a doctor
and you know you're you're a therapist
it led me down uh
very hard it led me down a path of a
different type of pornography that is
not that is not who I am
that the I did that type of pornography
just
because I was so desperate and felt very
alone and I still do feel very alone
till this day like he feels like every
day is a good Friday to me you know and
and I tried to go see a therapist and
you know usually therapists are supposed
to help you but I felt like this guy
reasoned more with what I was doing
then recognizing that it was a problem
and helping me switch So eventually I
stopped going I mean he was a nice guy
but I really didn't feel like that was
like he was helping much and I was okay
okay hold on stop
okay I got the gist of it
um
are you involved in child pornography
um no
um it's a diff uh if you want I can tell
you which type yeah
um well I started with straight
pornography but then I would go on this
uh video cam website and I would
masturbate with other men okay
yeah and that was the type that I was
doing and it goes completely against my
values as you know as a Catholic as a
Christian it goes completely against my
values as a man as a as a Christian as
as a person who goes and participates in
the Eucharist every week it feels wrong
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
yeah all right
um
do me a huge favor
yes take a deeper breath as humanly
possible that you could the biggest
breath you can feel in your lungs and
hold it for five seconds a count of five
one two three
four
blow it out as hard as you can
okay
now
thank you for being brave and for saying
stuff out loud that you've probably
never said out loud before
never what you've just done is hard okay
and you're gonna feel particularly
vulnerable and particularly exposed as
though you were Buck Naked you just
threw the windows open
um in front of a group a huge group of
people okay
I want you to sit in that discomfort for
a second because you're also going to
find that's where the healing starts
okay
yeah right now
your mom ran a pretty tight ship didn't
she
yeah
and you were a trophy correct
correct and she shined the trophy up
to make sure everybody in her world
could see how shiny you were right
correct and she protected you from
yourself because you weren't to be
trusted right
I'm sorry that you were
set off
on that Adventure because you were a kid
and you instead of being taught how to
trust yourself and that you were lovely
and worth being loved and that what you
felt and thought mattered you were told
you're gross you have issues that only I
can solve for you
and suddenly what emerged from that that
soil that she created for you
is a guy that doesn't like himself and
it looks at every other person who
interacts with him as you've created
stories and put them in other people's
heads and actions that they are acting
towards you in a certain way because
they're having fun at your expense
That's how little you think of yourself
Fair
correct I'd say that's Joseph you don't
suck you're not a loser
okay
cool
absolutely
in it I'm sitting here pretty fired up
that your mom never told you that where
was your where was your old man doing
all this
so we have a kind of kind of crazy
family story we almost lost our house in
2008 2009 my mom had over a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in credit card
debt that she eventually paid off this
took about us about seven years to get
done I know but where's your dad
my dad was working him most of the time
you know becoming gazelle intense so I
didn't really have him that much in my
life at a very young age he didn't
really come in much until about I was
about 11 or 12 or really I wouldn't say
until I was about 13 14. okay so he was
absent for some of the most important
moments of your life
correct
No hugs from Dad no dad doing bad times
no dad grabbing you by the face and
saying hey by the way I won the cosmic
Lottery getting you as my son none of
that
none of that it was it was very tough
period
okay
so here's what I want to tell you
we'll get to the negativity part
because you are um destroying yourself
and you know that so I'm not going to be
like your former therapist and try to
talk you into making peace with yourself
you have a behavior that you want to
change I'm here for you okay exactly but
how we ended up here is very common and
very normal
that's how I can hear two sentences
about how what your mom said and peel
back the entire story because I've heard
it ten thousand times okay correct so
let me ask you what does pornography
bring you
it honestly it brings me temporary
pleasure but it doesn't bring me
fulfillment hey don't try to take don't
take the back end of it off what does
pornography get you
it brings me uh satisfaction brings me
uh
it brings me a sense of of love it kind
of fulfills what a girlfriend is
supposed to do but since I can't get
that I I use this nope nope nope nope
see here's where you're wrong okay I
want to change all that right now
it isn't substituting for what a
girlfriend would bring you that's a
false narrative
what it does is it makes you feel like
you think you would feel if you had a
girlfriend this is about you not some
external person
yeah I understand that it makes you feel
like finally
this is what it would feel like to be
loved to be intimate with somebody
that's exactly what I feel yeah and then
you end up with a bunch of people in a
live webcam actually telling you
you're beautiful keep doing this you are
bringing me pleasure and you think that
you don't have that ability and so you
like that feeling even though you don't
like where you are and what you're doing
correct that's very true fair oh it's
very true you hit it spot on okay
here's why that's important because you
have to identify what pornography brings
you
because we're going to meet those needs
elsewhere okay
not going out and finding sex because
this isn't about sex this is about a kid
who hates himself
correct and hates the world that has
been created for him and I say that
intentionally because just until
recently you were a child
okay and I know you've been 16 and 17
having no dad you've had to grow up
quick having a mom who went off the
rails
um you had to grow up quick but you were
a child okay
yeah and so
here's what we're going to do to walk
out of this thing okay
and
um today's first conversation is a huge
start okay
absolutely
number one I'm going to give you uh one
two three four I'm gonna give you five
things okay
and here's what I'm gonna do because I
know this is torturing you right now
we're gonna clip this call and it won't
the show won't come out for you know a
month or so I'm gonna clip this call and
send it to you today or tomorrow okay
unedited all right because I want you to
have these five things and I want you to
play on Loop you are not a bad kid
got it absolutely none of this hap there
is no healing here
if you keep telling Joseph that Joseph
sucks
that's like looking at a wound that a
surgeon's just stitched up and you cut
it open again and you cut it open again
we have to start from a place of
Joseph's a kid that went through a lot
of nonsense and then found himself over
his head as a child and now as an adult
he's trying to dig himself out okay
that's a totally different proposition
then I got about 24 months left and I'm
eternally ruined
because that's not true okay it's not
true and this is a I'm in my 40s dude
I'm double double your life right yeah
I've had multiple ups and downs over my
heads what do I do now right and there's
light at the end of almost every tunnel
all right so here's what we're gonna do
first and this is an exercise between
you and probably a counselor
or somebody you trust who's an older
probably an older man
but here's the question we're going to
ask ourselves who are we going to become
okay right now you're trying to quit
porn
and you can White Knuckle it and you can
scratch and Claw and get 24 hours and
get 48 hours and get 72 hours and then
you're right back in it
because your energy is focused on not
doing a thing
okay
instead I want you to think who am I
going to become
who do I want to be what kind of adult
do I want to be I'm not going to be that
kind of dad who disappears on his kid
for a decade I'm not gonna be that kind
of mom who imprisons her children and
says it's for their own good right I'm
I'm gonna become this and then we're
going to start reverse engineering
behaviors that help us become that I'm a
guy that stewards his body
that means I exercise that means I I
don't eat the cereal bar in the
cafeteria every single morning and I
don't grab ice cream every time I walk
out even though it's unlimited I Love
College cafeterias
and I'm gonna use the gym
a couple of times a week and I'm not
going to masturbate 30 times a day
you see what I'm saying like this is all
wrapped up in I'm a guy that takes care
of his body I'm a guy that takes care of
his mind okay second thing is we're
gonna trigger we're gonna identify
triggers trigger identification what
makes what sets you off
looking at hot attractive girls on
Instagram okay then Instagram is deleted
30 seconds after this phone call is over
got it
yeah because you are choosing to enter
into a fantasy
that you can't control this is you not
going to bars anymore
because you're an alcoholic right this
is you taking all the booze in your
house and pouring it down the sink
because you're an alcoholic
you're gonna delete all of the apps all
everything off your phone and if you got
to go to a flip phone just for six
months go to a flip phone for six months
got it correct okay that leads me to
number three hurdles in roadblocks you
have to intentionally put things in
front of you that make access to your
addiction hard make it challenging and
by the way I also don't believe you
fully yes seeing hot girls on Instagram
cool that lights your brain up like a
Christmas tree awesome but I'm willing
to bet that when you feel rejected
or you feel exhausted but you can't
sleep when you feel wound up on the
inside out when your body feels anxious
masturbation is a release Fair
it is okay yes whenever you start
feeling like I suck I don't like my
major I don't know what I'm doing mom's
calling and Dad's texting
you can go to another Universe where you
are a completely different guy that you
can Captivate 15 men around a cam a
webcam you can Captivate Captivate three
women
who are imaginary you see what I'm
saying exactly it's when you feel
powerless so yes looking at pretty women
uh you're on a college campus for God's
sake dude there's gonna be beautiful
women everywhere
it's more than that it's when you feel
less than
exactly here's the moment though you're
gonna put roadblocks in there because
the rest of your life you'll have
moments of feeling less than I wrote two
dissertations one of which is now
required reading in on the topic that I
wrote on I've written one best-selling
book followed by a number one
best-selling book after that and I sat
down to write a new book recently in the
first 30 pages I wrote I just looked at
it and said I'm a loser and I don't know
what I'm doing
what an absolute scam I'm running here I
beat myself up for a long time
why do I tell you that you're gonna have
seasons of less than for the rest of
your life it's just called life and
you're gonna have to have some
roadblocks until you get control of the
addiction okay correct Fair
share
here's the uh here's the last one I'll
wrap it up with four
this is a huge start because you you
have admitted this in front of what will
be millions of people okay
yes
shame eats secrets for breakfast it's
one of my favorite brene Brown quotes
and shame is the thing that keeps you
walking around thinking you're less than
that you're broken deficient that you
suck that you're a loser you're gross
okay
correct the one antidote to shame that I
think trumps every other antidote
is saying out loud here's who I am to
other people
and so whether you find an essay Group
which I know they have in Vegas uh
sexual sexaholics Anonymous just a group
of men and women who get together and
speak openly here's what I've been
struggling with
and when you sit in a circle of 15 or 20
men or women some are 30 years older
than you some are 10 years younger than
you and you say I masturbate 30 times a
day and I can't stop
you'll see a room full of people all nod
and go yeah we've been there man
and suddenly your body completely
relaxes because you're not all alone
you're not the psychopath loser that you
think you are okay
correct you have to this isn't a I want
to strongly recommend you have to have
other people in your life that you are
regularly telling the truth to okay
exactly
is that fair that's very fair let me let
me be even clearer you cannot do this by
yourself this ends in ashes if you don't
exactly you were really really close if
you haven't already you are razor thin
close to meetups
exactly okay
correct Fair
yes and you've probably gotten pretty
dang close already
absolutely okay
take another breath and exhale real
quick
here's my promise to you I'll walk
alongside you the whole way okay
thank you so much John
tell me how you feel what does your body
feel right now
after hearing that and taking that all
in it I kind of feel like a big uh I
would say like a rock was taken off my
back that's been hunching me over for a
long time you know
it feels like you know
that knowing what you said it opens my
mind that you know there is that I'm not
alone there's a big there's always
a brighter future and that that there's
nothing that's ever impossible but it
takes some effort and it takes some work
on you know on the victim's part you
know well it's on the victim's part and
you played a role in it right exactly
and you were a kid
so now we're doing adult things I don't
hold children responsible almost almost
never because they're kids okay you're
an adult sometimes afterwards we have to
respond to kids actions right but
they're children
um you're you're gonna have to make
adult decisions now so here's where you
found yourself and now we gotta we gotta
take
um a right turn maybe Vegas isn't the
right Community for you
maybe I don't know
um maybe your group of friends isn't the
right group of friends
but before this day is over every app is
off your phone
or you've just gone down to at T or
T-Mobile or Cricket or whoever you use
and you're getting a flip phone that you
can't access
before this day is over you've looked up
and contacted and made it and put on
your calendar that you're going to the
next essay meeting there's probably one
tonight this evening in your local
community I guarantee you there's one
tomorrow morning
and we're gonna go
and we're going to tell the truth
in your counselor your previous
counselor sucked sorry find another one
it's not an excuse to not do the work
and let me be real real clear this is
gonna be hard
and you're gonna have days where you
fail miserably okay cool Shake It Off
we're on to the next
because we're gonna practice this new
identity as we move forward we're going
to practice it I'm this kind of I'm the
kind of guy who I'm the kind of guy who
I'm the kind of guy who and then one day
you're gonna meet somebody and you have
to sit down to explain to them dude I
was a full-blown addict
you jerked off 30 times a day yep yeah I
had a problem
and you're gonna feel nervous they may
leave you but we're gonna be honest
we're gonna be honest we're gonna be
honest
because you're worth being honest hang
on the line Joseph I'ma send you a copy
of own your past change your future I
want you to read it and cover to cover
and then shoot me a direct message and
let me know what you think and anytime
you want to call and be on the show I'm
here for you okay I'm grateful for your
for your bravery and your honesty
there are brighter days ahead my brother